claire foy and olivia have both won
golden globes for their roles on the
crown i want to know how does it feel
that you now you taking home the crown
tonight
and what's the community like between
the women on the show i'm not sure if
you noticed olivia cheering for you when
it when you won but it certainly seems
like you're all
very supportive of one one of each other
yeah i mean it was the most incredible
um incredible thing i mean it still
feels like it's sinking in i think it
will be a while until it really hits me
what's happened
um especially because we're so far away
from each other as you say i mean it was
amazing to have olivia there on screen
but i mean it would be so lovely to be
able to hug her in real life and to
share this moment with
all the cast and everyone who made
the whole experience of choosing the
crown so special you know
the next question goes to scott evans
from access hollywood
hello hello how you doing
[Music]
i'm good how are you congratulations
listen i feel like the reach of netflix
brought diana back into our living rooms
and through you we all fell in love
all over again i wonder if it has been
difficult for you to say
goodbye or goodnight to her and how
you're sharing this moment with josh
o'connor
you know you're so right about saying
goodbye to the diana it was um
something was on my mind as i was
filming the series i
every day when i went into work i felt
like how would i ever
how can i let you go like you feel so
close to that character because you're
so
consumed by playing them you know but
actually i feel like i
took her on such a journey playing her
from 16 to 28 and actually by the time
we finished filming i felt completely
ready i felt like i'd like done
like being with her through such an arc
that it was time for me to move on
and i'm so excited and i can't wait to
see what elizabeth
does with that part in the next series
um and i facetimed josh just now and it
was amazing
i mean i cried when he won i think i'm
so proud of him and i just
yeah i wish i could be there to hug him
and say well done yeah
the next question is for chris johnson
from gma
7.
congratulations emma uh the the award
was definitely well deserved
i wanted to see if you noticed when you
won all your fellow nominees were so
excited for you
especially sarah paulson she's doing a
little dance that's already kind of gone
viral online
what was it like to get such wonderful
support for all the women in your
category
and a quick second follow-up besides
yourself who do you think is most
excited for you to have won this award
tonight
thank you
um i mean to hear that i mean i haven't
actually seen that advance that
sarah did but to hear that i would there
was that much support from my fellow
nominees is just
mind-blowing i mean these are women who
i have looked up to and who have
inspired me for so many years
and you know women supporting women is
one of the most powerful things that is
that can happen you know it's so
important and so integral to progress
is being made at the moment in the
industry and in the world
as a whole and um it means it really
means the world
and yeah i mean and in terms of who's
most excited about my win i mean it
probably apart from my mum when she
wakes up
probably my agent who um
yeah he's wonderful so yeah
the next question was to russ weekland
from hollywoodlife.com
hello and congratulations uh the duke of
sussex
admitted he watches the crown while
talking with james corden
what would you discuss with him given
that you invested
so much time and talent into his mom's
story
to make it so real for us in 2021
um i mean it's difficult because
um with the crown and peter's version of
the crown it feels so
it is so fictional and it feels so
removed from
you know that the the actual world
family um
so on one level i feel like um
yeah it is so distant it feels so
separate but on the other hand obviously
um we are the characters are based on
real people and so there is something
there responsibility to acknowledge them
in some way and yeah i saw that
interview that he did with james gordon
and it was
i felt incredibly grateful to him
actually i'm incredibly moved by
by what he said um i don't know what i
would
what i would talk to him about i haven't
thought about it that much but um
yeah i'm certainly um certainly the way
he spoke about it and the fact that he's
watched it and the fact that obviously i
played his mother and that would have
been such a sensitive thing
um i was very moved by the fact that he
acknowledged it yeah
you